buenas noches de valeria y cuáles serán
las consecuencias de esta votación para
bolsonaro
puede que sean pocas porque la comisión
del senado solamente tiene poder de
investigación es decir puede hacer
interrogatorios puede investigar pero no
puede procesar a jair bolsonaro por esta
razón a partir de mañana va a pedir que
lo haga la fiscalía general del estado
el problema que el fiscal general
augusto harás fue nombrado a dedo por el
presidente yer bolsonaro y hasta ahora
se ha demostrado fiel al presidente y
para muchos juristas el informe final de
casi 1.300 páginas se puede quedar en
nada en un acto de oposición sin muchas
consecuencias ni siquiera avanzan las
más de 120 peticiones de impeachment
contra bolsonaro están paradas en el
congreso además se va a presentar este
informe ante el tribunal penal
internacional pero allí de nuevo primero
hay que ver si lo admiten a trámite
porque hay muchas denuncias y luego si
hubiese un fallo tardaría entre 7 y 8
años
bueno y entre tanto como afectado este
proceso de la popularidad del mandatario
bueno sin duda la popularidad de
bolsonaro se viene erosionando son seis
meses de comisión de investigación
y hoy hay varios sondeos que dicen que
más de la mitad de la población de
brasil considera su gobierno malo o
pésimo además en las prospecciones de
intención de voto para las para las
presidenciales del año que viene
bolsonaro perdería contra todos los
candidatos además de la gestión de la
pandemia hay un tema muy grande que es
la inflación que afecta especialmente al
precio de la gasolina y de los alimentos
y por esta razón tampoco la popularidad
de bolsonaro está muy bien bueno y
quería preguntarle también el sobre otro
tema que incumbe también al presidente y
a su popularidad estos últimos días
escuchamos anuncios del gobierno de
brasil en favor del clima
el vicepresidente de hamilton o morado
dijo que la meta era cero deforestación
para 2028 y el embajador para el clima
en glasgow paulino de carvalho neto
anunció nuevas leyes para alinearse con
los acuerdos de parís son estas
propuestas creíbles
bueno es que es complicado porque la
destrucción en amazonia parece imparable
en septiembre de este año se registró el
peor dado de la década el bosque
tropical más grande del planeta perdió
una superficie de mil 224 kilómetros
cuadrados lo que equivale al tamaño de
la ciudad como río de janeiro además
bolsonaro no ha confirmado su presencia
en glasgow y para muchos observadores
eso afecta negativamente a la imagen de
brasil en el mundo que ya está bastante
mermada el propio vicepresidente morado
serio no esta semana con varios
corresponsales extranjeros aquí por eso
y él dijo más de una vez que brasil es
responsable sólo del 3 por ciento de las
emisiones globales de carbono entonces
aunque consigan reducir ese 3% esto no
cambia la realidad de que la mayonesa
siendo deforestada y quemada año tras
año